Now that we have already seen how to split the data,
we will do some data cleaning.
Remember we have already decided that the location can be
represented as the distance from a point of reference.
We will go into depth a little bit later.
As to which distance function among these three might work best.
We will also need to decide on the times when we calculate these distances.
The distances at each time is a feature in our model.
We will also need to decide at what time intervals we choose these distances,
so that we can have adequate number of features.
We have now switched to the iPython Notebook again.
We're going to run the code to clean the data.
The code in block five takes the date and time, combines it into one
timestamp quantity, and makes the value reflective of US specific time.
It also makes sure that if some values of date or time is absent or
is equals, equals none those data points are not used in the analysis.
So let us run the code again by pressing the play buttons.
After you have finished running through lines six, seven, and
eight you will see an output.
The output has 128,520 entries.
This is down from 128,561 entries we started with.
The reduced number of events is a result of cleaning the data.